éviter que l'on dise blanc dans un
endroit et noir dans un autre je traduis
il y à beaucoup d'interprétations des
règles sur le confinement qui diverge
d'un point à l'autre du territoire
nous avons demandé au ministre de
l'intérieur ce qu'il fait ce qu'il a
fait ce qu'il compte faire pour assurer
l'uniformité de l'application des règles
sur le territoire et le respect strict
du droit nous avons une police
républicaine gendarmerie républicaine il
faut bien sûr que pendant la lutte
contre le coc u19 l'état de droit
continuent à s'appliquer et c'est très
important je sais qu'il y est sensible
ça veut dire que le gouvernement n'est
pas assez clair sur le confinement
qu'ils imposent aux français sur les
règles de confinement le gouvernement et
lui-même clair mais ça se traduit par
des milliers de décisions individuelles
et souvent on demande aux policiers et
aux gendarmes de faire des
interprétations qui sont un peut
apparenter à ce qu'un juge ferait et ça
n'est pas leur métier
voyez dans un supermarché à la sortie du
supermarché des gendarmes ont demandé le
ticket de caisse
personne n'oblige a gardé le ticket de
caisse ou vérifie le contenu du caddie
au cas texte de permet de vérifier le
contenu du caddie il ya comme ça un
certain nombre d'interprétations vous
êtes allez faire vos courses en vélo
vous avez été verbalisés est ce que
c'est normal
donc on a besoin d'eux d'uniformiser les
pratiques et nous allons insister sur ce
point qui est évidemment très important
pour que chacun sache bien à quoi s'en
tenir et pour le respect du confinement
le respect de l'autorité
c'est aussi très important